there's been a huge outpouring of
support for a Salt Lake City nurse who
was roughed up by a police officer the
shocking video has led to outrage and
caused the mayor and Chief of Police to
apologize Elaine Quijano has the story
this video shows Alex wills a head nurse
in the burn unit at the University of
Utah hospital being handcuffed and
arrested after she refused to let police
draw blood from an unconscious man in
the emergency room the victim had been
brought in after being in this fiery car
crash on July 26th near Salt Lake City
[Music]
wobbles told police it was against
hospital policy and the law to take
blood is evidence from an unconscious
patient unless the patient was under
arrest or the police had a warrant
detective Jeff Payne who was trained for
a special police blood draw unit
approached the nurse and demanded to do
it anyway in addition to the officers
body cam hospital cameras caught this
disturbing scene Robles has now hired an
attorney the only job I have is the
nurses to keep my patients safe we need
to remember these are officers of the
peace this was not peaceful this was not
even civil Alex wobbles was released and
no charges were ever filed
detective Jeff Payne was placed on
administrative leave the Salt Lake City
District Attorney has opened a criminal
investigation for CBS this morning
Saturday Elaine Quijano
New York that's just an extremely
disturbing scene yeah hey Lane said it a
night it's beyond that